let me talk about something that I'm
getting more and more emails about there
is no doubt that what would be best for
my show and shows like the David Pakman
show and other independent progressive
media shows would be for Donald Trump to
be reelected in November of 2020 I mean
that there's just no denying it
whatsoever but I'm getting more and more
emails from people with these
conspiratorial ideas about how deep down
I actually want Trump to win because it
would be better for my channel give me a
break okay this is a show that has been
my authentic and genuine opinion about
the world since day one I'm not stupid
or blind right like I understand every
progressive show host that I've spoken
to understands and agrees that we're all
doing way better because Donald Trump
was elected over Hillary Clinton
political interest has exploded Donald
Trump's outrageous behavior gets people
interested in the news and politics of
what's going on there's no question
about it I don't know any single serious
progressive host who would deny that but
do I want Donald Trump to win even if
some deep down place even if in some
deep down place I recognized that he's
better for my show than Hillary Clinton
would I want him to defeat Joe Biden or
Bernie Sanders or whoever is the
Democratic nominee no of course not and
this might come as a shock to you but
there is actually not a lot of character
playing in left-wing media what I mean
by that is on the right you have all of
these people who have had political
awakenings who just happen to be
political awakenings that move them into
a lane that is very profitable and very
well-funded on the right for example and
all of a sudden they have a whole
different variety of political views I
know that there are commentators on the
right who were really well funded by
certain elements of their audience to
the point that there's something called
audience capture going on and they're
almost even unable to articulate their
true beliefs because they risk
jeopardizing the funding that's coming
in I know that that exists that's not
this show and I don't know any
progressive hosts of the ones that I
personally know that is doing this sort
of character playing a calculation where
they say one thing on the show and
really they believe another one behind
the scenes and
to a fault because it hurt me in many
ways I've never modulated or modified my
views to appeal to specific slices of
the audience or whatever else even
though it would have been particularly
profitable so when I tell you that Trump
has to go for the betterment of our
country I mean it I'm not playing coy
with the reality that membership and
YouTube subscribers and podcast
subscribers the whole thing has gone up
way faster under Donald Trump than under
any previous president I'll deal with
the slower growth rate that I know will
come with the removal of Donald Trump
because it's the right thing and it's
what's correct and I will go even
further I don't even know for sure that
it's a drastic difference at this point
in time yes if Hillary had defeated
Trump things would have been much more
boring political interest would have
been significantly lower than it is but
now that we've had Trump I expect that
if Trump loses in 2020 he'll lose his
mind even with a Democratic president
there will be years of crazy stuff going
on and also I believe that Donald
Trump's presidency has had a sort of
irreversible change to American politics
that has been caused and things are
going to be wacky and interesting for a
long time so I'm also not even really
worried that the growth rate will be
significantly lower if Donald Trump you
losses so accuse me of something
reasonable you know tell me my
conclusions about taxation are wrong
tell me my foreign policy views are
missing something but telling me I
actually want Trump to win because he's
been good for the show give me a break
don't waste your time don't waste my
time with that nonsense